[Music]
[Applause]
don't leave him open Sean Elliott Spurs
TV analyst won a championship in 1999
two-time NBA All-Star and went to dinner
with Timmy and David and Manu and Victor
one by Amma and Coach pop
uh how does the dinner come about Sean
well I think it's something the Spurs
had planned for a while Dan you know
it's something that uh they put together
to just kind of Welcome him to the city
and welcome him with you know guys that
he kind of grew up watching play and and
the icons uh basically of the
organization so it was nice to see uh
Big Dave there nice to break bread with
Timmy Timmy's like Howard Hughes you
know he's just like a recluse you see
him every once in a while you're like
hey you know hey man what's going on I
mean he's just he's always in hiding uh
and and to have mono there was really
special and you know the thing I loved
about it most Dan I'll be honest with
you is when he walked in just to see the
expression on his face when he saw David
and he saw Timmy and he saw Manu was
something else he said there was like a
reverence there oh was he surprised he
didn't know that Duncan and David were
going to I I think he knew but it's just
that you know it you know I'm an old
commercial Legend right and it's nice to
see a young player that you know
appreciates the history of the game and
appreciates those guys that came before
him and you could tell that he really
appreciated those guys was there a game
plan during dinner
no no not at all uh we just uh you know
pop told me when he called me just hey
just you know welcome him and you guys
can ask him questions he's going to ask
you a lot of questions and that's
basically what it was and uh it was nice
because you know everybody around the
table got to go around and talk about
their NBA experience and and you know
what you can expect and you know give
him some some tips and some pointers
about how to prepare himself how to get
ready for the season how to endure the
gruel and so it was a it was a lot of
fun but you know on his end too he's a
very very mature young man Dan and he
asked all the right questions I mean I I
think we all came away from that dinner
just even more excited more enthusiastic
than we'd ever been give me if for
instance what was he asking because I
was more curious about he was what he
was asking more than what you were
telling him
uh just questions about how to prepare
your body how to get rest uh what the
travel schedule is like because you're
coming from playing 55 to 60 games to
playing 82. I think he wants to play as
many games as he possibly can but he's
already somebody who uh is very in tune
with eating it the right way getting his
rest uh you know he he asked us all if
uh you know how can you get enough sleep
on the road I mean what what kind of
young person asks that that question I
mean most guys are like hey what's the
best club to go to in Philly or New York
you know he's asking how he can get rest
on back to back and so uh again just uh
you know really mature and wise Beyond
his years but I'm wondering if you said
he could emulate David Robinson or Tim
Duncan Style
which which path would you point him or
maybe somebody else but just the fact
that those two legends were there
uh uh you know I think he's going to be
who he is uh you know I I give a lot of
credit to Dave and Tim I've said it over
and over again that the reason you know
the real reason the San Antonio Spurs
have been successful for 20 plus years
25 years is because David Robinson and
Tim Duncan didn't read the Superstar
handbook they're not Divas they're not
full of themselves uh they don't feel
like they're bigger than the franchise
uh very coachable guys and he fits that
mold perfectly uh you can ask for a
better young man to now take over the
reins but he also reminds me of what
Steve Kerr said about Seth Curry I mean
about Steph Curry excuse me he said that
he's very comfortable in his own skin
he's not trying to please a certain
crowd he doesn't care about all the
noise on social media he's just going to
go on and be himself and and uh you know
he sets high expectations for himself
and that's uh that's what he looks to he
doesn't look for you know outside noise
talking to Sean Elliott Spurs TV analyst
and two-time NBA All-Star
he may not have expectations he may not
want to listen to those that noise but
we're going to have expectations you're
going to have expectations you're going
to go okay what can we expect from him
so what is what is fair to him to expect
this rookie season individually in
team-wise
well I I think you're asking me and
you're you're asking the Spurs
organization you know I've talked to pop
about it uh a little bit and it's just
you know our expectations are realistic
I think fans expectations are always
unrealistic the media's expectations are
you know they're way out of whack uh
he's 19 years old uh he's gonna have to
have an adjustment to the NBA it's not
going to be easy he understands that and
so for me I'm thinking uh you know we're
going to be a much better team obviously
because of him he's going to make
everybody else better I don't know how
that's going to translate into wins but
right now if you if you ask Pop to tell
you the same thing it's not about the
wins and losses it's about developing
and getting better and getting a
foundation for his MBA career so I I'm
looking at this team I think we're gonna
yes I think we're gonna win more games
obviously I think we're going to win a
lot more games
but I can't talk about playoffs or
anything like that because you know
there's so many variables that go into
the season but do you think that and
I've said this it feels like there's the
transition will be easier defensively
than offensively for him that he will be
instantaneously impactful on the
defensive end
yeah I don't I don't think there's any
question there Dan uh you know I I've
heard people talk about uh you know he
needs to bulk up and he gets stronger I
think that I I just don't buy into that
I I really don't uh this isn't the 80s
or 90s anymore this isn't wrestling with
a basketball in the court is in there
era of the bad boys the NBA is not
nearly as physical as it was back then
uh so he's gonna get and by the way
playing in the European league in the
French league is a lot more physical
than playing in the NBA and he's been
playing as a professional since 15 or 16
years old against grown men that are 25
to 30 years old so it's not like guys
are going to beat him up that that
doesn't happen anymore in this league so
I I expect him to be very effective on
the offensive in the floor but you're
right I'm more impressed with what he
does on the defensive end because if
you're somebody penetrating you get in
the pain you're thinking about how in
the world am I going to get this shot up
over this big guy he's going to block a
lot of shots he's going to alter more
shots than he blocks and for the
offensive player going in there he's
going to be in the back your mind every
single time you enter the pain area and
not only that Dan he can move his feet
for a guy who's seven foot five still on
screen and rolls he's not a liability
he's an asset he can he can switch if he
has to on a point guard and he can space
guys if you've seen the tape he can
space guys you know five to ten feet and
still intimate date or block the shot so
uh I'm more impressed I mean we could
talk about watching them defensively I'm
more impressively does defensively than
offensively uh I think you're spot on
there Sean the Spurs put out a social
media video where Victor is shooting
jumpers
they gotta show him making the jumpers
he he made two dunks and like a
12-footer
is Popovich trying to Tamp down the
expectations Maybe
so I'm going what do you do
what do you do I who takes any stock in
that I mean it's fun to to laugh about
it for sure uh yeah yeah maybe they need
to edit that that uh film a little bit
but hey I'm not uh you know I'm not
judging him after you know on three
missed shots I mean there's no way yeah
finish this sentence if David Robinson
doesn't hurt his back
1996.
uh
poof
if David Robinson doesn't hurt his back
well it was his foot
first off he broke his foot
his whole career but he broke his foot
that year and that's what kept him out a
majority of season and I'll say David
Robinson doesn't break his foot no Timmy
Duncan no Dynasty yeah
yeah and Pop came on didn't he
yeah pop took over for Bob Hill that
year I think we were three and 15 at the
time yeah uh and so yeah I mean who
knows what happens who knows if if pop
is here who knows but you know I tell
you what uh pop
really did a phenomenal job that year
even though we didn't have David and we
went into the lottery you could tell
that guys were playing hard for him and
knew exactly what he was doing and he
was changing the mindset on the
defensive and the floor so I think when
I sat back and I watched it and when
Dave watched it we knew that pop was
going to be the right guy for the job
for some reason I thought it was his
back anybody did have back issues he did
you can have your guys check on that but
I'm sure that it was his he he broke the
outer bone in his foot and that's what
kept him out that might be one of the
great injuries in the history of sports
Sean
prob probably I mean you get Timmy
Duncan out of it and you turn it into a
20-year run of greatness and then uh you
have these four or five years we're down
years and you happen to get uh Victor
win benyama but you know the fact that
we get Timmy and the way he was as a
human being as a teammate uh you know
kind of it still reverberates and you
have a guy like Victor like I said he
walks into the dinner and he sees Tim
Duncan and you could just see his
expression and how he held these guys in
such high esteem
I went there Tim's rookie year
to one of your practices and you guys
made Tim carry all the basketball like
you guys are not hazed but I remember
that you you put him in his place when
he came in and here he is you know the
franchise savior
pretty crazy isn't it I mean uh you know
we weren't the type to uh you know
really give it you know big time to guys
I mean when I was a rookie I had to
carry bags I had to help unload bags off
the carousel every once in a while uh
but that was about it now guys to you
know bring donuts to the facility but I
can't imagine these guys hazing Victor
no no no I yeah I think they'll they'll
give them a little bit of crap they'll
give them a little bit I hope they do a
few menial tasks you know but it won't
get too bad uh everybody keeps uh
calling in they're trying to give Victor
a nickname
um we have the the French prince instead
of The Fresh Prince of Bel-Air uh the
the French choice
you put the French okay I like I like
that okay I I could I could roll with
that one how about escar goat
that's car code
you're a broadcaster I love it yeah
I love it hey escargot is awesome but we
got with that that one is going to be 20
years on from now oh let's see let's see
how the career developed in we'll call
him the escargot uh do you have a
Michael Jordan story for us
oh
I mean
yes I you know the the one story that I
tell people I I you know Dan I still
tell people that Michael Jordan is the
most underrated player in the NBA really
you know yeah you know why I say that
because every time somebody has a hot
month
or a hot year a hot month they go on a
roll you know there's a side screen
Michael and this other guy and you know
people just forget that there are two
sides of the floor
they don't take into account
competitiveness you know you can compare
Michael's stats but you can't compare
the drive uh the determination to win uh
it's almost insulting when a guy you
know comes out and has a 30 point or 35
Point month and you compare to Michael
Jordan that man was an absolute beast on
the defensive end of the floor he was
the greatest defensive player that I
have ever seen and when people start
comparing people just because of numbers
I think it's I think it's a travesty and
I think it's people don't know
basketball but I will say it was our
second or third year we went to Chicago
We're beating the pants off of them they
grew up 25 the middle of the Third on a
TNT game
and all Phil did in that second half the
fourth quarter is ran like a uh uh four
corners and I was guarding Michael and
he was throwing up you know here you see
that shot that he threw up in the
Gatorade commercial I say that was
Child's Play the stuff that he was doing
in that fourth quarter I I had to guard
him but basically they would get the
ball off the glass give it to Michael
spread the floor and he's coming right
at me one-on-one and it was a guessing
game that's all it is is he going left
to right so half the time I was guessing
incorrectly I was guessing wrong and he
was getting in there the tongue was
coming out he's flipping balls off the
glass left and right and the crowd's
going crazy stole a pass Dunked On David
Robinson we ended up winning that game
by one or two points oh boy and it was
one of the greatest uh performance that
I've been a part of and it was just fun
it was just you know for me it was a lot
of fun to be on the court at that time
you know you could get embarrassed every
time you're playing against it yeah but
so what so what I mean you're in good
company you're in good company yeah you
get you get a chance you know I I told
people that when I guarded Michael for
me Dan personally it was a thrill
if he scores 40 on you so what you get
that opportunity take on that challenge
why would people be afraid of that
moment I I don't understand that I would
take it as a challenge and I would
relish every moment of it even if he
dunked on me could you take him now
oh no questions
smoking cigars I'm about to go lift
right now man I'm about to go about to
go throw some kettlebells around he he
worked out Brandon Miller and he shot an
air ball from the free throw line
yeah yeah I don't doubt it man what if
the golf swings golf swing's not the
same as the junction oh come on
that's embarrassing I'm still in
reasonable shape Dan I'm telling you
yeah well you know free throw yeah you
shouldn't airball no I don't care no
especially when you were showing off
shooting them blind or you know shooting
them with your eyes closed in the game
great to connect with you and uh you'll
have fun this season thanks for joining
us as always Sean appreciate it Dan it's
been too long man that's Sean Elliott
former spur grape